by the way you're an amazing I love the
fact that you're so organized as a
lawyer Sean here all the laws in this
case Sean here
you're a great partner to have on this
show we appreciate it
laws potentially broken in the uranium
one deal let's put them up on the screen
so our audience can understand that
explain let's start there cuz this right
this was we sold out Nationals this is
huge the first six statutes on the
screen are the anti-corruption
pay-to-play statutes you cannot use your
public office Secretary of State to
confer a benefit to a foreign government
in exchange for money the evidence
appears to be there and because she used
her charity allegedly that would be
racketeering which you know the
government goes after organized crime
and the Mafia for that okay now so all
of these statutes these are real crimes
I keep saying we can't have a two-tier
justice system we can't have one justice
system for the Clintons that mishandled
destroyed classified top secret special
access program information all of these
issues involving the kickbacks the
paybacks that pay to play so the
question is how do we how do they get
away with it and do you think they slide
this time the Clintons are escape
artists that would make Houdini prowl
whenever they're caught dangling their
feet of the edge of illegality
they usually dummy up a Hillary Clinton
I'll give you an example interview by
the FBI said 39 times I cannot recall it
was so short because she could only
recall her name and date of birth we you
know she pretends like she's dumber than
a bucket of hair when it serves her
purpose and the brightest person in the
room when it helps her let's go to the
dossier crimes and the scandal accordion
that will put tempo them up on the
screen here this dossier is getting to
be a bright Baker because they paid nine
million dollars right you can't pay
millions of dollars to foreign nationals
because that's against the federal
election laws you can see here and you
can't hide it by Falling filing false or
misleading reports now I've been hearing
Democrats say oh those are just civil
penalties they are not the government
produces a book it's 319 page
is outlining the federal election laws
and all those who have been criminally
prosecuted and ended up in prison and
quickly the laws potentially broken in
the email scandal which now thankfully
is there finally this week they've
jacked to this the Espionage Act two
counts which were tortured and twisted
by James Comey and then the other two is
removing classified materials from a
government building the final one
they're destroying 33,000 documents
called obstruction yeah there was
repeated documents right yeah by
Congress all right Jay let me go back to
you I yep when you look at uranium 1 you
look at the Russian dossier
here's my question and where my mind
goes on this so the dossier they they
have the former mi6 guy he's my
confusion GPS he's paying Russians for
phony information and I've got a wonder
was that the information because Sarah
Carter and John Solomon reported that
there were FISA warrants another warrant
I'm wondering Wow
could they have used phony Russia
propaganda well ticket yeah but yeah
well let me tell you something if if in
fact the dossier was the basis upon
which a FISA warrant was issued you're
talking about a whole host of legal
issues that Greg will have to do another
chart because you're talking about going
to a court which is a FISA Court as a
court and getting a warrant to basically
eavesdrop tap listen in on conversations
based on a document that was not only
unverified as James Comey said by the
way and salacious and unverified his own
words but ask this question
why was the FBI considering paying for
it at some point in this process so that
question has to be asked and I go back
to this this whole concept which is
something we've been talking about for a
long time and that is if this dossier
was a political creature which we now
know it is no question about it was it
was who they call an opposition research
but if Christopher Steele was utilizing
Russian assets to get this information
and then of course it's been as James
Comey sent unverified and they went to
court to get FISA warrants you're
grazing a whole host of civil liberty
issue
and who knows what they did what they
said that permissible in a court of law
I filed motions to suppress the
subpoenas that have been issued in the
documents that were resulted as as that
I would file those my can name names
tonight the people that are happy real
quick the FBI has become this
all-powerful renegade deep state agency
they covered up the dossier information
they covered up the uranium one
information now that includes Muller and
that includes all reasons thing and that
includes call me right and Andrew
Weissman all four are on this Trump
Russia investigation and they are so
compromised here that they need to start
answering questions before Congress we